I won't let anything happen to her the
new frozen - trailer is revealing yet
cryptic at the same time it shows a
fascinating new creature that looks like
a magical underwater high source so what
does it deal with this new character
well just like Elsa we're diving in to
find out more the new frozen to trailer
reveals something pretty spectacular
while Elsa is underwater she sees a
magical sparkling water horse and uses
jolts of energy like lightning to
teleport itself forward in the water it
looks right at Elsa with its glowing
blue eyes before disappearing in a flash
of lightning this horse makes an
appearance once more when grand pabbie
is sharing a premonition it sparkles and
leaps around before shape-shifting into
a bunch of giants this new character
clearly has a significant role to play
in the story so what exactly is this
magical horse
well according to a press release from
Disney this new character is called a
new to quote this new look is a mythical
water spirit that takes the form of a
horse it uses the power of the ocean to
guard the secrets of the forest myths
about this creature began circulating in
German folklore many moons ago legend
has it that nuke would learn them to
their demise much like a siren of the
sea but what does this have to do with
Elsa we've got a major theory about
nukes connection to Elsa's powers watch
until the end to find out what it is
first let's discuss the powers of this
gluon or fab water beast according to
Disney a nuke can shape-shift into
anything at once but chooses to be a
horse that leads us to believe that the
powers are not in the horse itself but
in those flashes of lightning that
propelled the creature forward
we believe that light is related to the
mythical spirit that guards the secrets
of the forest
perhaps the spirit chose a horse because
it is significant to Elsa in some way if
the spirit usually leads men to their
demise why did it let Elsa's swim up to
the surface they must have some sort of
connection that plays a big part in the
film the horse appears to be beating
Elsa on her quest through the northern
forests the vision Elsa sees when she
visits the trolls shows this horse
leaping across the sky and then turning
into gigantic
monsters we know that this water spirit
has shape-shifting capabilities so does
this horse become the Giants that are
working to protect the secrets of the
forest that doesn't seem possible since
it's a water spirit and the Giants
appear to be made of stone
maybe the horse is leading Elsa to the
Giants to find out the secret about the
origin of her powers those Giants don't
look like they'll be very friendly or
informative so why would the horse be
leading Elsa Anna and the rest of the
gang into dangerous territory those
giants are guarding something in the
trailer Elsa and Anna come upon four
stone pillars with diamond-shaped
markings on them perhaps this is what
nook and the Giants are guarding but if
nooks in charge of guarding these
secrets why would he guide Elsa to the
spot Nook is just one of the magical
creatures in frozen - we also saw
massive stone giants and there is some
sort of magic pink fire floating around
the enchanted lands in the teaser Disney
released last February a new character
is revealed and it looks like she could
be manipulating the wind in the first
frozen film Elsa was the only one with
magical powers but now it seems that the
forest is full of secrets and magic
floating characters but just what does
that have to do with their horse that's
where our theory about Nook and Elsa's
powers come in if nook is a water spirit
and certainly there are other spirits
for other elements like earth air and
Fire there is a character who can
manipulate the air similar to how Elsa
can manipulate and freeze water
there's also another character or spirit
responsible for lighting those magenta
fires and certainly those stone giants
are controlled by some sort of magic
perhaps in earth spirits there are four
stones at anna and elsa approached in
the forest
these stones each represents one of the
four elements so what if each element
has a spirit and each spirit funnels its
powers through a person that would mean
that nook is Elsa spirit animal it's
likely that this magical creature is
responsible for Elsa's powers and Nook
is leading also to unites with the other
guides and subsequently the ones
wielding the powers of the other
the trailer leads us to believe that
those giants are a threat to Elsa
however maybe there is an even bigger
danger when spirit makes it necessary
for all four spirit elements to unite
those giants could be like Elsa's
creations Olaf and a marshmallow perhaps
there is a sacred little boy or girl who
controls the earth element they could be
using the stone giants to ward off
possible threats additionally we've seen
the girl who can control the winds in
the previous trailer but who's the one
who controls fire
maybe honor will surprise us in frozen
to when she reveals her fiery powers the
last theory is about the secrets of the
forest
grand pabbie said Elsa the past is not
what it seems but what exactly is he
talking about he clearly knows a few
secrets of his own
maybe these secrets have to do with the
origin of Elsa's powers well we finally
discovered just where they came from and
why she has them some have suggested a
curse but we think it has to do with a
natural phenomenon in the new trailer we
see a flashback of Elsa's mother looking
at the Northern Lights through a window
to the Northern Lights have something to
do with Elsa's powers
grand pabbie tells anna and elsa that
they must journey to the northern forest
where the Northern Lights are the
strongest
nuf uses some sort of light power to
transport itself through the water the
horse could be drawing his energy from
the mysterious Northern Lights in fact
maybe the Northern Lights have something
to do with just how magical the
enchanted lands really are what do you
guys think if you think the northern
lights are the key to Elsa's powers
leave a snow flake emoji in the comments
give this video a big thumbs up if you
can't wait for frozen to you to come out
and be sure to subscribe to the things
for more videos like this one thanks for
watching see you soon
[Music]